vous êtes rencontré comment déjà alors
on s'est rencontré il est venu me parler
sur Instagram
ça a duré quelques semaines mais je vais
lui laisser raconter parce que c'est
vraiment son histoire en fait moi je
l'ai contacté à deux bases pour le
travail au des plateformes etc pour des
informations et puis on a de suite
accroché moi j'ai senti qu'il y a
quelque chose au téléphone alors je lui
ai dit tu es où là là maintenant de
suite à Marseille écoute bouge pas
j'arrive j'ai quelque chose à dire bon
j'étais à Toulouse en fait je voulais la
voir j'ai senti qu'avait quelque chose
et je voulais qu'on parle de
tout
à Paris elle est au Sénégal mais il a
pris beaucoup
[Musique]
et dans la voiture tu t'es dit ouais
c'est le trajet il est long quand tu vas
comme ça tu dis ouais regarde à la base
c'était pas du tout de la drague hein
pas la drague après
ce qui vous a dit il m'a dit si j'ai à
Marseille c'est peut-être pour
rencontrer la femme de ma vie je me suis
dit ouh là le beau parleur
tout va bien
on parle de la différence d'âge donc je
suis obligé de vous demander 39 ans pour
toi gabano tu as des nouvelles de Dolce
et toi Nathalie 52 52
vraiment et Nathalie qui est magnifique
aussi hein mais vraiment et tu as pas
changé du tout un peu quand même ah non
je te jure que non tu veux que je te
dise je trouve plus belle maintenant
qu'avant
tu as raison je te jure qu'elle est plus
belle maintenant qu'avant et je le pense
vraiment et donc moi alors ça va
franchement là et vous êtes bien tous
les deux vous allez de quoi vous êtes
est-ce que vous avez des projets parce
que ça qu'on se pose souvent la question
énormément est-ce que vous pourriez on
est marié on est marié on s'est marié le
soir de Halloween avec chapelle vous
êtes déguisé on était déguisés
[Rires]
toi gabano c'est vraiment la femme de ta
vie honnêtement oui franchement
qu'est-ce que tu as trouvé qu'est-ce qui
a fait que c'est elle était plus que les
autres déjà c'est sa petite voix qui me
fait craquer moi je trouve qu'elle est
charmante elle est elle est apaisante et
en plus je sais pas même
professionnellement parlant je trouve
qu'elle a beaucoup d'ambition et
et puis je travaille sur les plateformes
de charme d'accord très bien et toi
de charme aussi d'accord avec Nathalie
vous faites des photos on fait oui on
fait des photos des vidéos sur sur les
plateformes que je sais pas si on peut
les citer non non voilà
donc voilà donc tous les deux et en solo
et puis à la base il est venu me parler
pour parler des plateformes il s'en sert
des conseils
du tout du tout vraiment pas en tout cas
vous avez l'air amoureux
ça fait plaisir parce qu'on a en fait
votre histoire on a voulu vous avoir
soit parce qu'on est parti de l'histoire
de Léonardo Dicaprio qui a quoi il a
quel âge Leonardo
48 et sa meuf à 19
ça va alors personne n'est choqué
personne n'est choqué
de différence avec ma femme à part
personne est choquée par Béa et Raymond
toi il est là toi l'amour pour ton âge
bah non check mon fils a un an de toi ça
te dérange pas
bien sûr ce qui compte exactement tu
sais l'amour n'a pas de frontière n'a
pas de âge et l'amour n'a pas de saveur
gilbertez j'ai une question pour pour
tous les deux quand vous êtes sur les
plateformes de charme c'est pour
cultiver votre désir mutuelle ou
simplement pour gagner de l'argent non
c'est du business
là j'aime bien parce qu'ils t'ont calmé
direct
et en plus de ça ça peut être très
compliqué parce que ça devient un
travail donc ça pourrait presque tuer du
désir c'est ça exactement fou c'est que
tu l'as dit Nathalie donc on peut le
dire c'est que ça te rapporte plus
plusieurs centaines de milliers d'euros
par mois
entre 300 et 500 000 à peu près
[Musique]
elle est en train de se dire
je ne suis pas morte non mais Daniel
Daniel est-ce que toi ça choque non non
alors moi la différence d'âge ne me
choque pas je trouve qu'on s'apporte
beaucoup plus quand on a une différence
d'âge que ce soit dans un sens ou d'un
autre j'aime le côté Pygmalion et je
trouve que voilà il y a plus de sujets
de conversation plus de débats enfin
c'est plus intéressant d'être avec
quelqu'un déjà aujourd'hui toi parce que
aujourd'hui je suis sorti avec un homme
plus âgé forcément
[Musique]
[Rires]
à 18 ans j'avais donc quelqu'un qui
avait 50 ans
là maintenant bah là tu ferais que des
sorties par la chaise
des hommes de 75 ans il y en a des
magnifiques
je suis pas du tout choquée par leur
couple à eux mais comme ça partait du
côté DiCaprio et en fait ce qui me
choque chez lui c'est que c'est pas
juste il a rencontré une personne il est
tombé amoureuse c'est un système c'est à
dire qu'il ne sort qu'avec des extrêmes
je pense que ça pose un problème il y a
une question d'emprise plus dans ma
famille il y avait un couple avec vingt
ans d'écart il y avait vraiment une
emprise et encore plus s'il y a une
célébrité ou un statut avec du pouvoir
et ça pose un problème donc quand la la
personne la plus jeune est très jeune il
y a une histoire d'emprise et en
vieillissant ça pose aussi des questions
sur la avoir des enfants peut-être on en
est pas au même dans sa vie et après le
à la fin de sa vie il y en a un qui est
forcément beaucoup plus âgé que l'autre
et c'est compliqué
que Delphine c'est qu'il est vrai que
celui qui est plus vieux va mourir avant
celui qui est plus jeune logiquement tu
vois ça c'est sûr c'est ce que je dis
tout le temps à ma femme j'ai un appui
pour long ça va aller oh non quelques
années bah il y a une pénurie d'insuline
j'ai peut-être mort dans 3 semaines
arrête avec ça
par semaine
mon enterrement ça c'est alors
franchement parle pas de ça parce que je
préfère venir à ton spectacle
arrête de parler de ça je vais dire il y
a eu des gens et il y a des gens ici
regarde Daniel tu vois 112 ans même
force de l'âge en pleine force de là il
décale
aux yeux toutes ces dents alors c'est
que des vrais c'est pas parlé tout neuf
voilà qu'on a remis comme ça la semaine
dernière comme ça
tout est d'origine elle est magnifique
Nicolas question pose pas de problème la
seule fois où ça peut me poser un
problème effectivement dans le cas de
Léonardo Dicaprio parce qu'il est
toujours avec des nanas qui ont 19 20
ans DiCaprio
on s'aime qu'on aime bien sûr moi j'ai
20 ans
là il a 20 ans de différence avec la
personne qui l'a fait bien sûr j'ai 53
la 33 ans problème je l'aime et on
s'entend super bien lancé
et ça vous arrive jamais vous avez
peut-être avec des gens ça peut arriver
au Touquet avec Daniel on a pas fait du
char à voile
pour avoir vécu des relations des hommes
plus jeunes j'ai eu des 20 et 25 ans
d'écart moi je veux dire que ça pose
problème quand la personne est très
jeune et qui Ava 25 ans d'écart parce
que à un moment donné il y a pas de
discussion il y a pas de suivi c'est pas
comme nous on a 13 ans d'écart mais on a
beaucoup de choses à se raconter il a un
passé j'ai un passé on a des choses à te
raconter une fille de 20 ans elle a rien
à raconter à son mari qu'elle a 50 elle
a pas de passer elle a pas de vécu un
moment donné ça va choquer
honnêtement moi ça me dérange pas chacun
fait ce qu'il veut mais ça serait ma
fille ça me ferait chier quoi
parce que bon déjà leurs différences
c'est pas eux c'est plus Léonardo
Dicaprio parce que lui il a 40 ans et
j'aime bien leur franchise de dire que
c'est pour le business c'est ça je le
souligne j'aime bien et pour Léonardo
Dicaprio je trouve ça quand même c'est
18 19 ans c'est c'est des femmes qui
sont nées en 2004 2005 je rejoins je
rejoins Nathalie qu'est-ce que tu leur
dis quand tu as 60 ans et que tu es avec
une gamine de 18 ans qui vient même
encore à l'école peut-être même
étudiante
lui c'est pas Titanic c'est titanus
c'est mon avis je pense que quelqu'un
qui a 60 ans sortira avec une gamine de
18 ans tu pourrais être en fait toi tu
es un peu comme tu disais à partir de 25
ans tout passe c'est fait à partir de 25
ans c'est voilà c'est différent
parce que Jean-Marie
moi j'ai 68 ans et
40 on a 28 ans d'accord rien n'est
choquant ici balade dans la rue tout ça
un autre tu changes un paramètre je vais
en Espagne qui est le pays de ma femme
bien sûr en Espagne les gens me
regardent comme un vieux village
milliardaire qui ce qui exhibe
toi le garçon de café il dit en espagnol
prend quoi donc c'est insupportable je
sais c'était
quoi alors que ici non mais pour dire en
Espagne
la notoriété fait que ben on trouve
évidemment plus naturel qu'un mec
milliardaire et en l'occurrence là une
mannequin qui gagne très bien sa vie bon
bah c'est moi je sais que non mais c'est
vrai que jean-marne en Espagne
parce que j'ai des potes espagnoles à
chaque fois qu'il me voyaient me disait
l'eau [__] passe bien là à toi
il disait que c'était une
ah non mais Jean-Marie c'est vrai que
c'est quand on change de pays et
toujours Marie et je vais te dire 40 et
68 GG ça mais ça passe moi quand je te
vois avec Lola franchement ça passe
je te remercie
tellement belle histoire d'amour
Delphine regarde là on est beau là en
fait quand on a pas vécu ça forcément on
a envie de on a envie de juger moi la
première avant que ça m'arrive je me
disais que Ben que les vieux c'était des
vieux profiteurs et que et que les nanas
c'était peut-être des michtos qui
allaient pour l'argent mais je peux vous
dire que en fait même sans argent quand
l'amour en tombe vous tombe dessus et
ben on ne choisit pas après il faut
juste gérer le regard des gens et c'est
vrai que le regard des gens peut être
relativement accusateur et moi je me
souviens de d'un moment où on était allé
visiter un appartement et l'agent
immobilière elle a dit ah oui vous
pouvez montrer à votre papa la salle de
bain et tout ça tu as envie de dire bien
sûr si tu as un doute ne dis pas ne dis
pas si c'est ton copain ou ton père
genre juste ne dis rien quoi et c'est
vrai que maintenant par expérience étant
donné que j'ai vécu ça je ne pourrais
plus aller avec quelqu'un de mon âge
parce qu'effectivement c'est tellement
intéressant que tellement enrichissant
voilà
je réagis à ce que c'est l'emprise du
Caprio comme si j'étais un prédateur qui
abusé une jeune fille c'est n'importe
quoi
elles l'ont certainement
etc il a pas été Léonardo Dicaprio
je suis désolé les mecs faut arrêter
c'est pas non plus
c'est c'est DiCaprio les mecs on a rien
c'est un mythe bien sûr mais tous les
hommes autour de cette table en plus de
succès depuis qu'ils sont autour de
cette table que avant
j'avais plus de succès quand je garais
mon camion en créant que
fallait me voir faire quand je dois
relever le t-shirt et que j'ai tout
petit j'avais mon petit
curieux l'amour a t-il un âge là c'est
pas forcément de l'amour quand tu te
caches que quand tu as 50 ans et que tu
vas exclusivement avec des filles de 19
ans parce que vraiment que tu recherches
ce type de femme là c'est pas que tu es
amoureux
c'est naturel
je suis comme Monsieur j'ai apprécié
heureuse
DiCaprio sur toute sa vie sur toutes ces
conquêtes amoureuses il est jamais tombé
amoureux d'une nana de 30 ans 35 ans
jamais tout droit le maximum qu'il a
fait c'est 24 ans
quand on dit goût on a un peu
l'impression que c'est une attirance
physique ça peut être une attirance
céréale
physique il peut après peut-être
exactement
est-ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter de
l'amour alors de l'amour ça y est il y a
un bon bowling ce soir
ça y est et là on est en train de on a
un gros projet tous les deux qui va
tu vas naître dans un mois je pense
voilà c'est un enfant
professionnel
merci beaucoup merci d'avoir été là
merci